welcome to basse gesta from the only
teams we know what good the Patriots you
told me this was an indoor lacrosse game
the Ravens ahead with the shortest game
and redefine it in my image please
welcome your host Kirk Cousins I think
good it could only be one purple team
guys the game hasn't even started yet
first up are the Eagles good no but they
will win the division correct is this
all you need us for next up are the
Steelers good scared mess with their
heads but I will mess with their minds
okay the Rams no I think the correct
answer is we don't think so but it feels
weird to say out loud okay lightning
round Raiders yeah maybe oh yeah man
Cowboys know Texas won this battle but I
will win the war and the morale wins
stay tuned for our Nets game show the
NFL's cap workout we plan this in a day
all right listen up man sometimes you
hit the subscribe button and sometimes
the subscribe button
it hits you but the important thing is
to smash that like button in your dream
I can only comment section that you
should care about is one inside your
heart